Bachelorette and the runner-up Nick
speaking out to us for the first time I
mean he's the man that everybody wants
to hear from so why did Nick tell
everybody live on TV that he was well
intimate match the red Andy I put him on
the spot when it came to eg earlier
today and here is how he explains it why
did you bring up the fact that you had
had sex with Andy why were you willing
to tell the world well I mean I was
probably as caught off-guard that I or
surprise that I said that does anyone if
you weren't in love with me I like why
you made love the thing I don't well
first of all I think that's kind of
below the belt it wasn't just about the
sex it was more to me about the intimacy
maybe if I could have just articulated
that a little bit more because you know
we were two consenting adults like it
wasn't like she owed me anything because
that happened you know when she came out
I was you know obviously was in a mostly
charged environment I had just got done
watching you know the finale like
everyone else and I was will take him
back I think by her demeanor and very
cold little cold there was seem to be
like complete lack of empathy and and I
think I was so taken back by that were
you in love with him I was not in love
with him how hard to hear that what
producers have encouraged you to ask
that question would they certainly did
in yeah I don't know not absolutely I
mean I was I take full responsibility
for my my actions and words but I came
out afterwards like they said that yeah
they were surprised as anyone so you
didn't plan on anyway going and asking
that question no not at all I mean who
cuz Oh live television expecting to drop
that bomb you were recorded on the plane
without your being known yeah a lot of
firsts I suppose from you Josh wants
like he'll do whatever she wants he just
might have a bad temper
I was a mess you know that was like I
think a day after it ended I was
confused and and heartbroken and I had
just flown in finally to the States
I've had my phone for the first time I
reached out my parent and say hey I'm
back in the States
you get in trouble with the show uh they
weren't happy with me in that recording
you know I was might a little bit hard
on Josh you know certainly wish I could
you know take some of that back you
still in love with her now um I think
Monday night was a lot of closure for me
that I needed not necessarily about the
question but again her whole demeanor in
the process there's a whole lot more to
the story were they a good match in the
fantasy suite I mean you know what I
mean
could that have been what was wrong well
I asked Nick for the truth now that we
know that you guys did make love you
know had sex um was the chemistry
lacking in that wake at that of buddy
I mean not my mind um no I mean I the
whole the whole experience like what I
loved about the relationship they've had
is how much we both you know throughout
when you watch it back but we both
talked about our emotional and a mental
and physical connection and ya know it
was heavy
I felt good about it um it was ever
effortless you're blushing over there
now that's that you're welcome we
interviewed Andy the day after service
final rose and this is what she had to
say it definitely blindsided in a sense
you would hope people wouldn't put on
national television but you know what it
happened it's over it's done I'm glad to
have put that behind me and reaffirms my
decision with Josh absolutely they have
since called it classless disrespectful
vote Josh and Andi but you're saying
that's not what you intend and that's
what I attended I'm respect
you know obviously you know josh is a
good guy he's gonna support his fiancee
and I've absolutely respect that
honestly I don't take it as shaming me
on national television like I'm a woman
I can do what I want these days and if
someone wants to air dirty laundry then
it's more shame on them like I don't I
have a fiance that loves me that knows
everything about this process
back to that oh I'm glad she doesn't
feel shame because that certainly wasn't
my intention so that means a lot that
she she feels that way I know it was a
difficult situation for everyone but I
wasn't even trying to air dirty laundry
for sure I mean like I would have loved
the opportunity to have a conversation
in private but you know when you go
through a breakup like that and then BAM
it's over like it raises a lot of
questions and doubts and wondering
that's how people deal with you know
breakups it wasn't a show to me it was
real life you know is hurt and sad as
I'm about how things ended I it doesn't
stop me from wanting them to be totally
happy well as many naysayers as you have
you've got a lot of fans - a lot of
women who thought you were very
emotionally open would you ever be the
bachelor would you do it if they got
leaves anyone would be flattered to even
be considered but that again I would
have to talk to my family I mean I don't
know I mean I would have to make sure
like my heart is open and ready for for
that and in fairness to myself and those
other people so it would be flattering
to be considered they haven't approached
you yet no they haven't said anything to
me